hi so I went to the hospital last night
because I got hit in the eye with a
pickle now there's been a lot of
speculation as to why whether it was my
fault whether I fell landed on a pickle
whether I was just flailing pickles in
my room like I usually do and just
happen to jam it in my eye I was on a
commercial shoot and I can't give too
many details about it but they were
doing something to distract me by
throwing and launching food at me from a
catapult now I wasn't wearing goggles by
some oversight I guess it'll make more
sense once the actual thing comes out
but a lucky pickle went rogue and landed
directly into my eyeball causing me to
go temporarily blind in part of my eye
so I finished the commercial and then I
went to the hospital they didn't have an
ophthalmologist on staff so I had to
wait overnight to this morning to go see
an ophthalmologist so they could look at
my eye there is some severe bruising on
this side of my eye which makes the
blind spot over here because of the
flipping thing that happens in your eye
and it should be fine I don't know if
it's gonna be fine ones wanting to
follow up with a retinal specialist over
there in Europe when we're going on tour
for this bad-boy tour right here which
I'm leaving for in exactly an hour so I
don't have a lot of time Warsaw I'm
gonna end this here so thank you guys so
much for watching guys you would be fine
if you let's I go blind and then you can
all laugh because I lost an eye to a
pickle